there are at least 11 trillion reasons
to worry about what joe biden wants to
do to our economy
and our freedoms he campaigned on a
platform that the washington post
called more liberal than that of every
past
democratic nominee he's bad news not
just for the economy but for a
wide range of libertarian concerns such
as school choice
individual autonomy and the first and
second amendments
when biden warned in the last
presidential debate
that we're entering a dark winter he was
referring to covet 19
but it's his policies that are most
likely to keep us stuck at home
and out of work biden is proposing 11
trillion dollars in brand new spending
over the coming decade among his biggest
ticket items
are 1.4 trillion dollars to expand
obamacare
two trillion dollars for his version of
the green new deal
one trillion dollars in new social
security and supplemental security
income spending
and 1.5 trillion more dollars for
preschool k through 12
and higher education he's also signed on
to a
3.3 trillion dollar stimulus spending
plan
pushed by house and senate democrats
that all comes after nearly seven
trillion dollars in federal spending
this past year
up from a then record 4.4 trillion
dollars in 2019
to pay for this new largesse biden has
laid out 3.6 trillion
dollars in tax hikes over the coming
decade resulting in what the manhattan
institute's brian riedel calls
the largest permanent tax increase since
world war
ii but biden's spending plan is laid out
in his campaign is so
out of control that he would still
manage to increase the national debt
by about 5.6 trillion dollars by 2030
according to the committee for a
responsible federal budget
just as scary are biden's seemingly
infinite promises to push
new government controls into virtually
all aspects of our lives
he wants to repeal section 230 the law
that protects online platforms from
legal liability for speech
generated by users and he wants to take
a really hard look
at breaking up tech companies especially
facebook
he's called for an end to federal
funding for charter schools and the
reinstatement of
ineffective assault weapons bans and
countless other gun control measures
pick any page of his campaign website's
extensive vision section and you'll find
endless proposals to tinker with
virtually all aspects of
everyday life and employment he pledges
to aggressively regulate
all contractual agreements between
employees and employers
especially those in the gig economy and
he wants to establish an environmental
and climate justice division
within the u.s department of justice in
joe's agenda for students
he promises to require aggressive
methane pollution limits for oil and gas
operations
while also making four-year public
colleges and universities
tuition-free for all students whose
family incomes
are below 125 000
biden was a punchline for much of his
half century in the public eye because
of his constant gaffes and scandals
but he is also a battle-hardened
politician whose time may have finally
come
joe biden's likely season in the sun
comes nearly
50 years after he first entered national
politics
and he may well usher in a dark winter
that will persist
long after next spring's bloom